الاخبار اهلا بكم هلا مراسل الجزيره ان
القوات الاحتلال الاسالي قتلت شابين
فلسطينيين وذلك باطلقها النار على سياره
الكنايه يستقلانها قرب قريتي جبع جنوب
مدينه جنين كما استشهد شاب ثالث نصيب بها
في مواجهه مع قوات الاحتلال مطلع هذا
العام
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا واعتبرتها خطوه حاسمه في
العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
في المقابل قال متحدثا عسكريا اوكراني انا
روسيا لم تسيطر على المدينه وان قتال
عنيفا ما يزال مستمرا واكد ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تزال تدافع عن مواقعها
بالمدينه اعلنت نائبه الامين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون السياسيه روزماري دي
كارلوس استعداد الامين العام للواسطه بين
موسكو وكيف لانهاء النزاعي في اسرع وقت
ممكن
واشارت خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان
الوضع في اوكرانيا لانه لا تلوح في الافق
نهايه للقتال او المعاناه في اوكرانيا
الا وزير الخارجيه التركي
حزب العمال الكردستاني للرئيس التركي خلال
مظاهره في السكان يعتبروا جريمه كراهيه
واشار الى السويد كانت قد تعاهدت بمنع
حدوث ذلك وعليها انتفي بعودها اذا كانت
تريد دعما تركيا للانضمام الى النجف
السويديه ما شهدته مظاهره للرئيس التركي
في استقال وقالت انها تتفهم رد فعل انقر
على ذلك من جاته قال رئيس الوزراء السويدي
انما اقدم عليه المتظاهرون فعل مقزز وسيئ
نقل صحيفه السيد جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان اداره ايضا تستعد لطلب موافقه
الكونجرس من اجل بيع طائرات اف 16 لتركيا
واقل المسؤولون الامريكيون ان الطلبه
على انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى النيترو
هكذا الرئيس الامريكي
بدفاع عن اليابان باستخدام لكل قدراتها
بما في ذلك النوويه وقال بيان المشترك في
ختام قمه جمعت بيض برئيس الوزراء الياباني
في البيت الابيض قالوا نتحالف البلدين
سيبقى حجر زاويه لحفظ الامن والسلام في
المحيطين الهندي
بالقوه في اي مكان بالعالم
كتاب الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]